I was a breakout YouTube star in the
first year 2006. I decided that the
right strategy was to leave YouTube
completely and go to viddler because
vidler offered me equity in their
company I deviated from my intention
thesis to do short-term economics and
equity in a company and I lost when
drock finally came to my life two years
ago we started to try to build up my
YouTube for the first time I was sitting
on 40 000 followers in a world where I
could have had Millions if I just stayed
the course so I make mistakes all the
time I'm reorging vaynermedia every day
because it's based on a mistake I made
the prior year I just don't think about
my mistakes everybody else cares about
your mistakes if you're worried about
your own mistakes you've already lost